des vidéos de surveillance prises à 5h
dimanche elle montre l'arrivée des
fidèles à la mosquée Aluma à Montréal
puis cet homme qui tente d'entrer par
effraction dans la salle de prière en
fracassant violemment des vitres
sortaient et qui a sorti de 6 à sortir
puis la police il a attrapé heureusement
il n'y a eu aucun blessé mais
l'événement laisse quand même des traces
la plupart des gens qui étaient là se
sentaient très menacés par des
prélèvement il se souvient de
l'événement qui était qui était arrivé
en 2017 le 29 janvier 2017 à Québec le
suspect a arrêté par les policiers est
un homme de 32 ans suite aux
informations reçues et aux éléments
analysés que les policiers étaient en
possession ils ont mis en accusation le
suspect un homme âgé de 32 ans pour
avoir commis des méfaits l'enquête se
poursuit pour l'instant le SPVM ne
confirme pas qu'il s'agit d'un crémeux
d'autres accusations pour votre portée
contre l'accusé il a été libéré avec la
promesse de comparaître en cours le 9
mai prochain à Montréal c'est tolérance
zéro pour tous types d'infraction et
tout type de violence surtout dans les
lieux de culte c'est non Marc Miller le
député de Ville-Marie qualifie cette
attaque d'islamophobe il écrit que les
fidèles doivent se sentir en sécurité
lorsqu'il sera semble pour leur prière
mais ce fidèle refuse de céder à la peur
ça m'a fait mal ça m'a ça m'a fait
mal mais non j'ai pas peur je vais ça
m'a donné peur il continue de croire que
le Canada est un lieu sécuritaire ici
Charlotte Dumoulin Radio-Canada Montréal